vielleicht solltest du dir einfach nur
lose kaufen die oben
etwas weiter ist dann kannst du dir
besser anfliegen willkommen beim ein
video wie heute ich hoffe euch geht es
gut mir geht das licht bin ich eh genug
so grad
es muss auf jeden fall ist mir gestern
auf gefeiert kann schon lange was ist
mega lange also bestimmt schon so drei
wochen kein jungs mädchen thema mehr ich
weitere schau dir mal sehr sehr gerne
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht komm macht
und fans ein video zum thema das habe
ich mir noch genauso wie letzten wahl
vorgeschlagen und fahren weil ich doch
mal bitte über probleme reden von
mädchen die jungs nicht verstehen er gut
daran erst mal so was ist denn für
probleme keine ahnung deswegen habe ich
euch wie immer auf knöpfe gefragt wenn
ihr mir nicht folgte macht es auf jeden
fall mal kurz kurz eigentlich die ganzen
mädels was sind eure meinung nach
probleme die ihr habt die wir absolut
nicht verstehen und es kam locker 2000
einsendungen also ehrlich der folge der
mega krass eben ich habe mir ein paar
rausgesucht was sonst wird man zusammen
an wird sagen wir fangen an
warum schließlich wollte für das nächste
junges mädchen thema sind 10-15000-6
drin oder also weiter voll körperlicher
dann mit dem erstens nämlich
betriebswirt habt jungs können es nicht
verstehen wenn ein mädchen einen
fingernagel abbricht wir warten woche
darauf dass die lang wachsen und werde
abbricht weil das alles umsonst
ok also ich meine das ist jetzt nur
fingernägel geh einfach zu irgendwann
juni laden da gibt es ja genug und holt
auch dann einfach diese aus kunststoff
zum draufkleben die sind dann gleich
auch schon blau oder rot in den
regelungen drauf oder so glück sein
gestreifter musste gar keinen nagellack
drauf waffen einfach aufkleben und du
hast ja einige arbeit gespart damalige
ich mich auskenne
auch das natürliche fingernägel deutlich
mehr wert sind also kunststoffteile
zumindest bei euch mädels also ich muss
sagen ich verstehe ich auf jeden fall
oder ich möchte auf jeden fall davon
zeit wird aber ganz ehrlich jetzt sind
fingernägel die wachsen auch wieder nach
ich zum beispiel mich auf meine
fingernägel gar nicht die usa
ich schneide die manchmal sorgfältig mit
der schere und dann mit der nagelfeile
also ich kümmere mich schon
ich sehe meine fingernägel so der
nächste kleinere im sommer und man hat
keinen haargummi dabei online die welt
geht und habe mir auf also sowas wird
echt gar nicht auch mal total
aufgeschmissen mit meinen langen haaren
im sommer und dann habe ich nicht mal
ein kaugummi dabei das problem verstehe
ich jetzt um erste seien überhaupt nicht
lange haare im sommer und kein haar mehr
dabei dann hatte lange haare im sommer
und kannst ja nichts umsatz machen ist
vorsichtiger da müsst ihr mir dann jetzt
mal in die kommentare schreiben was da
denn jetzt das problem dran ist keine
ahnung die julia child mädchen müssen
über alles und jeden scheiß 3000 mal
nachdenken werden jede lösung ab und
schätzen die risiken ein und jungs sind
meistens eher so wie sie denken darüber
nach haben die lösung oder sie juckt es
gerne tun ich glaube mein nächstes
youtube video wird ein porno das blut
bestimmt viele klicks erledigen sind mir
scheißegal ich bin ein junge
also da muss ich jetzt mal ein gretchen
ich meine kommt jetzt natürlich auch auf
die situation an
aber jungs denken von auch noch also ich
bin jemand zumindest der auch nachdenken
und nicht nur macht natürlich wenn man
mich jetzt meine youtube anschaut macht
auch viel zeit aber ich weiß auf jeden
fall was du sagen willst das ist halt
viele mädels gibt die halt viel
nachdenken und unzufrieden sind mit sich
selber und dann gucken kann ich doch
jetzt noch machen wie es mache
vielleicht zufrieden mit euch denn das
ist wichtig für und habe ich ja auch
schon länger abgesagt
es wird jetzt darauf eingehen wir machen
einfach weiter mit dem nächsten punkt
aber jungs sind sich auch durchaus über
risiken bewusst und lagen genau wenn
mädchen einen neuen bh haben und die
ganze zeit daran rum zupfen weil sie ihn
noch nicht gewohnt sind ist auf jeden
fall genau das gleiche bei mir wenn sie
neue unterhosen hab ich erstmal immer
ein bisschen druck weil ich noch nicht
gewohnt bin wie die vips
also hört ist jetzt zum ersten mal dass
man das halt irgendwie noch zurecht
zupfen muss weil er sich allein laufen
musste zum beispiel mit der note alex
mbh muss man ein laufen wir aber klingt
auf jeden fall logisch nur bei
unterhosen wird zum beispiel zwei mir
entweder diese zeit gut oder halt nicht
und da kann ich dann auch nicht
einlaufen das problem wenn ein mädchen
zufällig das gleiche oberteil wie ein
anderes mädchen an hat nein nein das zu
recht das ist wirklich ganz kritisch das
wird auf keinen fall um ehrlich zu sein
das verstehe ich verstehe das wirklich
überhaupt nicht und
ich werde auch nicht verstehen weil
natürlich es gibt sehr viele oberteile
sehr viele verschiedene hosen und so
weiter
aber das ist doch jetzt nichts
schlechtes wenn einfach mal deine
freunde aber so das gleiche art wie du
oder das gleiche oberteil oder halt doch
irgendwie anders vielleicht nicht kennt
aber das ist doch nichts schlimmes ich
meine dann hat diese person hat den
gleichen geschmack wie du und regt halt
dann einmal aus versehen das gleiche
oder wenn ich jetzt natürlich durch das
die die immer alles nach kaufte das
finde ich auch mega scheint also chaftar
aus dem paar spezialisten ich denke wie
kopieren mein style aber man kann sie
auch einfach als kompliment nehmen ich
bin ein influenza wir kommen zum
nächsten problem wenn das shampoo noch
was voll ist und die spülung schon fast
leer ist verstehe ich auch nicht was mit
meinen shampoo kenn ich spülung hätte
ich mich also ich kenne die eine
klospülung
das passt ja nicht zusammen
also da müsste mich bitte auch mal kurz
in den kommentaren aufklären das shampoo
ist noch voll und die spülung ist schon
fast leer muss man vielleicht wenn man
lange haare hat bevor man die haare
wäscht sie spülen und vielleicht danach
das muss ich jetzt mal kurz googeln das
kann jedoch durch den gebrauch einer
spülung leicht unter kontrolle gebracht
jetzt habe ich verstanden als wenn man
seine haare wirklich selber auch beste
lange haare hat die dann vom shampoo
platzt dann muss man ab und zu mal eine
spülung rainer damit die haare nicht
kaputt ach so und du hast dann wirklich
immer spülung rein weil deine haare so
kaputt sind oder weil jetzt habe ich das
auf jeden fall ein bisschen verstanden
nur vielleicht als fern von mir
natürlich man kann ja jeden tag duschen
gehen weil man sich täglich wird oder
sonst aber nur zu einfach nur jeden
zweiten tag shampoo mache ich zwar nicht
aber das wäre halt vielleicht gehört so
weil auch die jetzt jeden tag deine
haare mit shampoo west oder halt nicht
ist glaube ich auch egal ob ihr nächstes
problem wenn man die hose nicht denn an
bekommt weil der arzt hätte alles klar
weiß ich jetzt nicht so ganz genau was
ich zu sagen soll ich mein ich habe das
problem er zwar nicht aber ich kann das
problem nachvollziehen
vielleicht solltest du die reifen hose
kaufen die oben
etwas weiter ist dann kannst du dir
besser anziehen ihr könnt ja weg in die
kommentare schreiben wie gut ihr meine
tipps findet also ich finde auf jeden
fall ausgezeichnet okay das ist
vielleicht auch das fan voting mädchen
hatten
ist duschen zu gehen oder zumindest ihre
haare zu lassen weil sie danach fünf
stunden zum trocknen brauchen nimmt auch
einfach in köln
ich weiß es dauert dann auch zehn
minuten aber nicht fünf stunden
irgendwie glaube ich gar keine youtube
videos zu drehen sondern probleme von
mädchen beraten weil das kann ich
irgendwie auch gut ja auch nicht schwer
die alle tun
neben es letztlich bild oder so aber
kommt wenn man da keine lösung findet
dann weiß ich aber auch nicht mehr leute
ich glaube das war eine zehn probleme
die ich mal eben bisschen analysiert
habe wie gesagt wir auf jeden fall das
netz hat und vielleicht auch bei inter
bleiben und bei 15.000 gibt's nächstes
jungs welche video ich wünsche einen
traumhaften tag und wir sehen uns dann
morgen und 14 und schon wieder foult ein
gutes video hart sein